well let's get the latest then on the
situation on the ground in Ukraine from
retired Vice Marshall Sean Bell and Sean
the big question here is why has Russia
then decided to pull out of this grain
deal yeah I think it's worth providing a
bit of context to this so Ukraine is a
bit of a bread basket for the rest of
the world and brain a grain export so
particularly important for uh out of
Odessa but of course Ukraine is also
paranoid that Russia will do an
amphibious attack into Odessa as well so
this deal was always incredibly Fragile
on Saturday the Russians reported a
massive attack against its Black Sea
Fleet out of sevastopol involved seven
Maritime unmanned vehicles and nine
unmanned air vehicles we've got some
footage here that's been shared by
Ukrainian social media the reality of
which sky has not been able to validate
this as yet Russian claims that all of
the unmanned Vehicles air and Maritime
were destroyed but it also admits that
there was some minor damage to its
frigate it's worth putting into context
that the Russians also said there was
minor damage to the muscover some months
back when of course a couple of days
later that vessel was sunk but returning
to the grain deal itself that was always
due to be reviewed in November and but
overnight Russia's said it's pulling out
of it straight away now because it's
claimed it can't guarantee the security
and safety of the civilian ships
transporting the grain out of Odessa
Russ has also claimed that this act
against sevastopol was a terrorist act
from point of fact the Russian military
vessels have been involved in Act of war
with Ukraine that makes them completely
legitimate vessels and if they were the
grigorovich class of frigates which is a
cruise missile frigate then Ukraine's
been suffering for many days and weeks
of attacks of cruise missiles absolutely
legitimate Target from Ukraine
perspective most of the drones what all
the drones look as if they were shot
down maybe not militarily significant
but strategically really important for
Ukraine to demonstrate it can attack a
long way away from the front line and
from the West perspective it's really
Keen Ukraine doesn't attack Russian soil
but of course Crimea is absolutely fair
game also why the situation then on a
ground looking like well if we um again
we're focused on back mood because we're
under most of the country at the moment
Russian forces seem to be digging in for
the winter they're bringing all of these
recruits in but around bahmoud a lot of
really intensive fighting still going on
lots of the reservists being brought in
huge casualties on the on on the Russian
side and they are making progress but
it's about 100 meters a day which is
woeful from a military perspective the
Wagner group remember that mercenary
group they're the ones who are leading
here they normally recruit high quality
people ex-military widespread reports at
the moment that they're actually
recruiting convicts and those with
underlying health conditions like HIV
and hepatitis C really are evident that
they're focusing on quantity not quality
at the moment and just bring us up to
date then with the latest that's
happening around the Hearthstone region
some claims coming in from Russia yeah
Hearthstone is really important
strategically because if Russian does
pull out of it it's a major setback for
Russia we've been trying to report on
what's Happening we've seen heavy
weapons come EAS so we thought that was
a precursor for withdrawal then we've
watched Russia push people in the honest
answer we've not don't know exactly
what's going but what really interesting
news that's come out over overnight that
the Russian 18th century Statesman
Prince Gregory potemkin who's linked to
Russian conquests of Ukrainian lands in
the 18th century his remains were in
Harrison Cathedral apparently they've
been taken out of that Cathedral and
taken back to Russia now given Putin's
fascination with the history of the
Soviet Union this appears particularly
symbolic and from a military perspective
why would you take out the remains if
you had if you intended to stay in
person for the long term that is a the
key question there very interesting
development there Sean thank you very
much indeed as Sean Bell there